um which is an incredible
statistic for for the people and i think
i know what you're getting at for the
people
that say a lot of conspiracy yeah it's
all it's all bs
i've read the the the scientific reports
i was there i know what the decisions
were
anyone that is saying seven world trade
center was an intentional
government conspiracy theory blah blah
blah
is is misled at the nicest or a
conspiracy theorist
who wants to make money at it at the
worst
and there are those people out there so
there was no
um plot
there was no government plot anything
that had anything to do with what
happened on september 11th
this was an al-qaeda plot
blessed by osama bin laden carried out
by khalid sheikh muhammad
and in his band of terrorists
who had promised after the 93 bombing
they had promised that they'd be back
they promised it after the 93 bombing
and they made good on that
uh
what was the 93 bombing again that that
was the world trade center
so cleed shaped muhammad's uh family was
involved in that also
okay so this is all related to
radical islamic terrorism with hatred
for america they call america the little
the great satan in israel the little
satan um
that's all this was and so for people to
hold on to these conspiracy theories
to give them any credence uh
angers me because it takes away from the
truth of the story right
and the truth of the story that radical
islamic terrorists who hate
hate what america stands for planned
and executed this successfully um
in fact we believe that the second plane
was timed
to crash in after the firemen and
policemen got there
because of the first one so they
actually timed it
so that they would kill more firemen and
kill more policemen
and we have some anecdotal evidence of
that
do you get a lot of conspiracy type
people no
reaching out to you no no you know i
mean i think they kind of know to stay
away from me
right i'll i'll i'll wipe the floor with
them with facts you know
right um
it's it's all bs um i i don't even
in the beginning i got pretty angry
about it now and just like yeah that
guy's a nut
you know right whatever that's not what
happened
i was there my friends were murdered
you know i have a reason to
know the truth on this and uh i promised
my friends i would never forget
so explain more about your friend who
was a navy seal you were saying that
anyone who comes out
who talks to him or claims that they
hate muslims or whatever he jumps down
their throat yeah why is that
because he fought in muslim countries
right he was injured in karma iraq
trying to defend innocent iraqi people
from the bad guys the bat from the bad
iraqi people from isis
slash al-qaeda in order for his
seal team to survive there they had to
rely on communications with
in support of good iraqi muslims
including his interpreter right which
they call turp right that's
military term right and
this his terp
would was one of the most american love
and p
loving people he ever met and would wear
the american flag and would dream of one
day being
free in america and
when you paint muslims with one brush
as being one way or the other it's not
true
and you you weaken the strength of these
people who want freedom
um and there are a lot more
muslims certainly in america
who want that freedom than there are
muslims who want to attack us right
um
and i i think that's who i fight for
by challenging the black the bad guys by
going after the bad guys by prosecuting
them by
confronting them in the media
confronting their lies
the people i'm helping the most are the
innocent freedom-loving muslims of
america
and that's kind of what i'm most proud
of is
is that we give them we we give the good
muslims
room to breathe and and
uh uh
i'm as proud of that as i am about
fighting for the memory of my friends i
guess
i never thought of it that way before
but um
we have to be able to discern the
difference
it's hard yeah because they lie
sometimes
imagine that yeah people lie
um there was like an overwhelming sense
of of camaraderie and patriotism
in the country after that um
why what was that like and why do you
think
why do you think it was like that and
what was your experience with that
it was something that all americans
could rally around
right america was attacked
at the pentagon on the plane flight 93
which they were trying to crash into the
u.s capitol
and in new york city um
the attacks were so egregious against
america
that it united americans of all stripes
and then we didn't see that again until
the night that we learned osama bin
laden had been killed
when those spontaneous patriotic
american
rallies popped up spontaneously all over
america
i'm sad that
that's what's required um
for me that we need to have an enemy i i
guess
yeah we should be like that more often
you know we should be like that
a lot of the time shouldn't take
something like 9 11. yeah
i hope not i hope not you know
um i mean back back
then i i i was
i was in a washing machine
just spinning around i i i couldn't
see anything i couldn't hear anything i
didn't know what was going on in america
i didn't
i didn't know anything um i knew when we
left
ground zero that when we went out on the
west side highway all the
people were out there with american
flags and signs and
screaming i love you and thank you
um but i i was not
in a a place where i really understood
what was happening out what was
happening throughout america
um you were you kind of had tunnel
vision i i was
just completely overwhelmed completely
foreign